لقد اعتقدوا أنها كانت ألعابًا نارية أولاً ،
لكنها كانت
محاولة اغتيال سافرة ضد
الرئيس الفنزويلي نيكولاس مادورو ، وكانت المحاولة
الأولى لقتل زعيم عالمي باستخدام
تكنولوجيا الطائرات بدون طيار التجارية التي تم شراؤها عبر الإنترنت ، وكان من الممكن
أن تقتل الجميع على المسرح ، كل
عشرات المدنيين القريبين منها.  غاب
عن الجماهير المتناثرة وبدأ الفنزويليون
يتساءلون ما الذي حدث بالفعل هل
كان مزيفًا حتى الآن قال زعيم المعارضة
هوانغ جويدو لشبكة CNN إنه أدان
الهجوم ويعتقد أن مادورو نظمه
للحصول على التعاطف الذي انتهى به الأمر إلى جعلهم يبدون
كضحايا قال أعتقد أن هذا  كان
شيئًا داخليًا قامت به
الحكومة ، وبالتأكيد لا توجد مثل هذه
الخيارات ليست جيدة ، فقد تعقبت سي إن إن
أحد المنظمين الواضحين
للهجوم الذي قدم هذه الفيديوهات التي
شوهدت هنا لأول مرة لإثبات
دوره فيما يدعي أنه
اغتيال حقيقي  محاولة لماذا خططت
لقتل نيكولاس مادورو
هذه حركة احتجاجية سلمية
لماذا كنت تعتقد أن مؤامرة اغتيال؟  كان من
الضروري أننا جربنا كل
طريقة سلمية وديمقراطية لوضع حد
لهذا الاستبداد الذي يلبس نفسه على أنه
ديمقراطي ، ولدينا أصدقاء
محتجزون تعرضوا للتعذيب.
هذا القدر الكبير من الانفجار على
الجمهور الذي كان يمثل الخطر الذي كان
علينا تحمله ، فنحن نهتم بذلك لأن الشعب الفنزويلي
دائمًا ما يشعر
بالعواقب المترتبة على شراء الطائرات بدون طيار التي يقولون إنها تم
شراؤها عبر الإنترنت في الولايات المتحدة
وتم إحضارها منذ أكثر من ستة أشهر إلى هذا
المستأجر  مزرعة في مكان ما في كولومبيا
، لا نعرض لك تفاصيل كيف
يقولون إنهم صنعوا قنبلة هنا ، لكنهم
فجروا إحداها في اختبار وفي الريف البعيد
، تدربوا على الجزء الصعب من
تحليق الطائرات بدون طيار عالياً بما يكفي لعدم
رؤيتها ثم  لأسفل بزاوية شديدة الانحدار وسريعة
بما يكفي لضرب هدفهم في
خيمة حديقة هنا حتى أنهم يجربونها في
الليل
في حال جاءت فرصة
الضرب في وقت لاحق
يقولون إنهم  قاموا بتفكيك الجهاز
للتسلل إلى فنزويلا ، تظهر مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بهم
أنه يجري إعادة تجميعها ثم جاهزًا
قبل ساعات من هجوم
رئيس الهجوم ليو في عرض تقديمي
بعد أيام من هجوم وزير الداخلية الفنزويلي
يؤكد جزءًا من قصة المهاجمين
بما في ذلك مسار الطائرات بدون طيار
التي تم تفجيرها قبل الأوان.
قال المنظم إن حاصرات إشارة الخلية التي تحمي مادورو من الهجوم قد تم إيقافها ، لكن فجأة
عاد عند توجيه الهجوم ، اعتقد
مستشار الأمن القومي الأمريكي جون
بولتون في صباح اليوم التالي أنه ربما يكون قد
تم تزوير ذريعة أنشأها
نظام مادورو نفسه  شيء آخر ،
لكن المسؤولين الأمريكيين الذين تم إطلاعهم على
المعلومات الاستخباراتية خلصوا إلى أن
الهجوم كان محاولة حقيقية فاشلة
، وقال المنظم بشكل منفصل إنه
التقى بالعديد من المسؤولين الأمريكيين ثلاث مرات
بعد الهجوم بعد أن عقدوا ثلاثة
اجتماعات أتصور أنها كانت لجمع
المعلومات من أجل  دراسة الحالة لكنها
لم تتجاوز ذلك وأنهم
يعرضون المساعدة  ع حاولت شيئًا كهذا
مرة أخرى أو كانت هذه الاجتماعات تدور
حولهم لمعرفة المزيد عنك ، أعتقد أن
كلاهما أراد الحصول على معلومات ،
ثم طلبنا أشياء في المقابل ،
قاموا بتدوين ملاحظات حول هذا وسألنا عما إذا
كان بإمكانهم المساعدة  ثم غادروا ببساطة
مع ملاحظاتهم ولم
يظهروا مرة أخرى أبدًا لم تتمكن CNN من العثور على دليل على أن
هذه الاجتماعات المزعومة قد حدثت ،
ولم يعلق المتحدث باسم وزارة الخارجية
على هذا الادعاء ولكن يقول إن
سياستنا هي دعم انتقال سلمي
في فنزويلا
قال المسؤولون الفنزويليون المؤامرة التي  هز
عاصمتهم بمساعدة كولومبيا
والولايات المتحدة  الذي نفى كلاهما أنه قد
كشف النقاب عن مزيج من القوة المميتة
والبراعة باستخدام تقنية
بسيطة بشكل مرعب للحصول على نيك باتون
والش سي إن إن بوغوتا كولومبيا